and the vice president was reportedly  furious over the photo that vogue used  when she was featured on the cover  wearing converse sneakers but biden's  team told her to back down because it  was quote a first world problem here's  the thing  she she posed for the photograph in the  outfit  right and now i know that they were they  were told oh yeah we'll probably use the  other one whatever they maybe they  thought they had assurances but when you  go you don't control the editorial of a  photo shoot you don't so if you don't  want to be film you just want to  photograph wearing your sneakers on the  front page of vogue don't wear them  don't ever do it and that you could  blame her staff if she wants to blame  somebody else don't blame anna wintour  whatever she should blame